I also feel that you have made a little
bit of um I'm watching you and maybe
it's because you're young and getting uh
older and More in in tune with you seem
to be getting more and more mainstream
which is not a bad thing no that's so
nice I mean you said you're going
towards your Sophia Grange era yeah I'm
rebranding you know I I and my
rebranding I really just mean growing up
like I've been growing up in the public
eye for so long and I think I was
a little crazier like more wild you know
I still am with the things I say but I
think that I've always just had a really
dark sense of humor so I'm now I'm in
the point where it's like you know I had
so many years where I was afraid of
getting canceled or not being brand safe
quote-unquote and now I think
I don't know in my opinion I feel like
things are changing back to the ways
where it can't be like listen I'm a
comedian and I want to say these things
and they're a joke and I'm joking and
people are you know almost getting less
sensitive again which I like well if
somebody said what are you I'm just
pulled over by that if somebody said
what are you Tana are you a comedian
sometimes you know I feel like I do a
lot of different things I'm an
entrepreneur and Entertainer and all
that kind of stuff but I'm just happy
that I can kind of write off the things
I say as comedy again you know I always
feel I think about this with my daughter
I have a daughter who it's so different
than when I was growing up and I'm a lot
older than you when I was growing up I
made some dumb dumb mistakes but there
was no social media like my my life
wasn't on social media I wasn't posting
everyone goes through whatever they go
through and they grow up yeah and it
must be so hard to you know post stuff
on the internet and then look back and
be like maybe I shouldn't have posted
that or I want to be looked at a
different person do you ever think about
um or are you totally okay with
everything you've ever put out there
well I see a lot of people in my space
kind of have that crisis like in the
middle of their career they're like why
did I say all this and put all this out
there and whatever I think that I threw
in the towel towards that mentality a
long time ago like what's the point of
you know harboring regret towards
something I said five years ago I think
with the way I was raised and the life I
had like I'm lucky to have gotten here
and if that comes with a bunch of public
mistakes on the way like you know you
know the the truth of the matter is the
difference between your generation and
mine I don't think any I don't think
they're that different in the sense that
we grow up and when we're You're Young
and Wild and you make mistakes and
that's how you learn and that's how you
change the difference is with you guys
it's there yeah it's there for everybody
to see for eternity well it doesn't go
away like I she talked about some of the
[__] that she's done I could talk about
it and remember it it doesn't really
exist on the internet yeah people can't
pull it up and I have friends my age
yeah that are getting canceled for what
was done 20 years ago which is just
crazy am I boring
[Music]